[Music]
I've been
thinking I can't run this club
forever I built this for
nothing this is my
[Music]
family you and me
kid from the
beginning yes
please
I was a golden age bike rider I never
felt so out of place in all my
life that's when I saw him for the first
time and took my breath away I'm
[Music]
Benny 5 weeks later I married
him I thought I could change him you
know not to be different but to be I
don't know like he's wild hey told you
to take that jacket off
you'd have to kill me to get this jacket
off oh
yeah what about the
bar bur it
down the club got real big real fast
they started running drugs gambling
prostitution is that what this club is
now I want you to quit riding don't ask
that
Benny I need you
you can't hand him if he wants to ride a
bike you're right B
yeah
[Music]
yeah hey you know
just just think it over you
know
[Music]
fore
for
give
[Music]
hey head of the wedding of my sister yes
I I am so where's your fiance wait is
this him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass
on your break wow you are a child it's a
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Creatine and smells like insecurity
nothing small about me what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this girl
is a
[Applause]
disastrous look going to our wedding
sorry is it going stranger what's going
on over there they dated she crushed his
heart that man does not have a heart no
way honey look who's here who is that my
ex Jonathan my parents have been trying
to get us back together he's like a son
to us maybe we should just tell everyone
we're together what it would s that
problem for me and you clearly want
Margaret she seizure with me she wants
what she can't have there's no way we
can convince anyone we actually like
each other you know I still think about
that night we spent together shut up no
I'm
serious no matter how it ended it's
still pretty
[Applause]
amazing convincing enough let's do it
honey here he is oh no I'm with Ben so
is it like we just got together or we
need to sinking around let's just be
affectionate Showtime permission to put
my left hand on your right buttock
granted not a magic
lamp hey little guy God damn it see you
tonight we have to take up and nice
touch nice TR oh no no it's going to
beot when are you ever going to learn
[__] it it's
fine Titanic me are they watching are
they doing Titanic they're gone show's
over oh my
god do you have a mo or something on
your butt
no what
the one might be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to checked and what I did it's a bad
idea right what did we miss what did we
miss [__] it it's
[Music]
fine gotcha so you're the funny little
man who's been following me funny little
man how dare you I will have you know
that I am a perfectly respectable size
for an OA Lumpa NOA what now in fact in
lump land I am regarded as something of
a Whopper they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed
T inventor may I present Willy Walker's
wild and wonderful wishy washy Walker
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the world
ooh he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send Wonka
a message do not sell chocolate in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head I love a bonk on the
head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
bullies give them the old one
too I got an idea where do we start make
chocolate of
course run away every good thing in this
world started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
world
[Music]
in
PRI good night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well
huh you did it again tell me what it is
or I shall poke you quite viciously with
a cocktail
[Music]
stick shots fired shots fired all units
please
respond
no
[Music]
go
hi baby boy talking to the fishies you
and me son we're different we special
we're connected to the land and the sea
I can't wait to introduce you to all the
majestic creatures on our planet show
you how awesome this world can
be yeah you and
me I'm going to kill
[Music]
Aquaman even if I have to make a deal
with the devil to do
it free me from my PR and all my power
will be yours the key to this prison is
the Royal bloodline
itself he needs us we're The End Of The
Bloodline no we're
not
yeah Manta took
Juni he must be
stopped I'm coming for
you destroy everything he holds
deal You Want
Blood come get
it where's my wife I shifted
her what do you want with me
this is not my
world I've never been to this Lake
before never walked its
Shores but I will find my way back and I
will find my way back to my
Molly 5 years ago I was left in this
dark
place
taken from my
wife the of the people here have no hope
youed to looking for that wife of yours
you're clinging to scraps of rumors and
then he
arrived where's my wife I shifted her
for every choice you make there are
countless other realities where we make
a different choice we talking about
parallel Earths imagine having the power
to move move people from One reality to
the next to shift
them what do you want with me I can make
you a king imagine everything you have
ever
wanted work for me and get back with the
woman that you love okay we go on a date
and maybe we kiss hopefully he's to
shift you back to your wife a
trick I Choose You you that's the last
Choice I'm ever going to
make I will never leave you
alone I've seen a bunch of people like
us out there looking for a little
help there is nothing that I won't do to
you let it sh Let It Shine Let It Shine
you can't just shoot the
devil there is so much evil and inh
Humanity in this world but there is also
Beauty and hope and I will find my way
back to
her hi I'm Elizabeth tabish and I'm so
excited for you guys to see my latest
project from Angel Studios I play Molly
Garner in the shift which comes out this
December Angel stud Studios theatrical
releases have always sold out the first
weekend so be sure to get your tickets
now you can get them at angel.com
theh illumination legendary villain is
back in an allnew short you wouldn't
happen to know how to get out of here
would you bye
[Music]
Moon don't miss Moon only in theaters
with migration this Christmas there's a
the whole world we've been missing out
on what is that dange dange it's you
with Lan on top migration plus Vector
rated
PG oh look what the Cat Dragged In good
afternoon
e how's your day Dad it was a day just
another day my day was a doozy one of
those days you never
forget listen up this young lady is our
new prison
psychologist she may be easy on the eyes
but I assure you she is very
smart I'm Rebecca I
know I don't think I caught your
name
oopsie nasty habit that's why I like it
I live a little differently than most
people they probably scared to
you prison is no place for a young lady
you got a big life ahead of you I'm sure
I'm just kind of average I think you
really think you're a normal
person I bet you brilliant
dreams alen may I confide in you people
are so ashamed of their
desires I have my own ideas kind ideas
you can never tell anyone do you
understand promise me
okay blood will make you
crazy BL will make you
pill can't imagine you with a knife can
you imagine me with a
gun that's very good E Yeah I can see
it you're different these days it's
almost interesting secrets and lies some
things are so
Twisted the only way I ask for someone
to
[Music]
die that was a great
trick I'm not an enforcer I'm more like
a um a
fixer exactly
I have to convince a certain person that
the buddy in that trunk out there is
indeed Rolo something happened to his
face what the it's Miss along with the
rest of his
head betrayal is a funny thing it's very
naturous to catch you
unaware you ever heard a ring doorbell
we're under
attack stance
gone
and you should be too I've always heard
one rule CH be good to the people who
were good to you be good to yourself
Charlie and get as far away from here as
you
can you turned on your own you ought to
get out of buuy Charlie that's what
everyone keeps telling
me that 50 Grand could really change
things for me I'm going with it without
[Music]
you that's Charlie I got more men than
you got bullet bullets bullets are easy
to
get what do you want you not breathing
and how you going to do that I'm doing
it you know you really ought to start
thinking about an Exit Plan what are you
waiting
for pull the trigger
[Music]
Charlie you're in over your
head like loose
hands he was my second best guy I'm
looking forward to meeting number
[Music]
one ever since I was a child people said
my family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with God
pop tried to protect us with wrestling
he said if we were the toughest the
strongest nothing could ever hurt
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please
David Carrie I want you to join your
brothers in the ring yes sir I love that
now we all know car's my favorite then
Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change what do you
want in life you want Eric more ribs I
want to be with my family you know be
with my
brothers what do you like to do with you
Brothers Harry and
[Music]
David together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that were passed down to us the
hands that were delivered with the iron
clock to
you so what do you think like we're a
lot I love your family
Kevin you going to be an uncle yes sir
oh man that makes me so happy I talk to
you about something M Dad's too tough on
us you got to say something babbe that's
what your brothers are for you feel that
you feel that that's
pressure May you're pushing too hard I'm
fine GI seriously I'm just
sick I'm scared hand and all my head of
control was a terrible accident I should
have stopped him I need to think about
my family your job is to wrestle live up
to that deal where we are through let
look out for him I just love being out
there with you guys it's the only thing
that matters to me the will forever be
the greatest family in the history of
wrest
[Applause]
[Music]
here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
uncle
danin
what is this place we are completely
lost was you
mother that is not your
mother we're trying to get to
Jamaica
simp don't worry CH gotcha so listen
Chum what did you just call me sorry I
thought your name was Chum yeah chump
yeah that's my name what right so listen
Chum what said you just call me I'm
sorry is everyone else hearing
Chum what
[Music]
this isn't about migration it's about
Adventure who whoa whoa whoo
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that dange what's
dange it's you with laange on
top there's a whole World we've been
missing out on and
we when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this
crazy wonderful
Adventure
you're so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm
kidding where am
I
huh go go
[Music]
[Applause]
go
mahito
so you made
it mother have a
seat it's this way
mahito a lot of strange things happen in
this place he join us I just hope he
stays
safe save me save me my what exactly are
you Dear Mother she's awaiting your
rescue I'll be your
guide what is this
place this world is filled with the
dead I know it's a lie but I have to
see I'm looking for
someone let's
go we must protect this world ourselves
go back now Mel
Mel you and I aren't Ben's or Allies
kid don't let go no matter what
[Music]
ready you see this
world there's more work to be
[Music]
done
a gray Heron once told me that all gray
herens are liars so is that the truth or
a lie a lie
truth we have to be alive
[Music]
too there are some moments in life you
never
forget the depression HD everyone hard
no jobs no food we were broke looks like
you still owe balance on this
semester so what's that about making
some money yeah the ran team you you get
a part-time job included she place to
live Amman crew is the most difficult
team sport in the
world the average human body is just not
meant for such
things most of you will not be chosen
beautiful speech
coach they announcing the teen today are
you going to make it we rode out of need
come on boys the need to stay in school
the need to to eat to sleep we got to
keep these right long as we stay on the
team Washington Huskies coach is
bringing an inexperienced vote to the
competition they said we couldn't
compete with the rich of school for the
nation the Washington boat has taking
the lead Washington has done it I got 9
seconds under the course record Olympic
year this year Olympic GE I didn't
realize that bunch of kids Lo like no
one else that's ever come through here
everybody else tires they just get
stronger we have it both and I believe
could qualified for an Olympic spot hope
you know what you're doing they said we
couldn't beat the Germans we got to beat
those other schools first but coach says
we had a shot maybe we can roll as a
team if you guys don't get yourselves
figured out you're not racing at all
boys that
boat fer but they didn't understand who
we were let's show what was in this
book I don't believe what I'm
[Applause]
seeing
best they
connected sweating
pain what it's worth I'm proud of you
boys inspiring uh you missed the part
where I told him not to tip over and I
rooll for your country rooll for each
other for all the people who never
believed in you eyes one has
one
[Music]
I am Bella
Baxter I'm a flawed experimenting
person I seek outings and Adventures
Bella so much to
discover you're the most beautiful woman
I've ever seen I am finding being alive
fascinating Bella why I keep it in my
mouth if it is
revolting I must go punch that baby
we must experience everything not just
the
good but degradation shall we sing
[Music]
horror sadness sah and we can know the
world and we know the
[Music]
world The World Is
Ours we more no more
andols too
much how did you come to write this book
what really struck me was that too few
books were about my people where are our
stories where's our representation would
you give us the pleasure of reading an
excerpt yo Shir girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
monk your books are good but they're not
popular editors they want a black book
they have a black book I'm black and
it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they publish look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses in
it I be standing outside in the night
dead beat dads rappers crack you said
you wanted black stuff that's black
right I see what you're
doing we sold your book no we believe Mr
Lee has written a bestseller it's a joke
the most lucrative joke you've ever told
now is stag a sudonym yeah Mr Lee can't
use his real name is this based on your
actual
life yeah you think some [__] ass
college boy can come up with that [__]
no no no I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that not me they ran
300,000 copies your books change
people's lives they're offering $4
million for movie rights yes the Dumber
I behave the Richer I
get this has gone too far stag arly is
still on the run from authorities you
haven't done anything it's not like they
can arrest
you it is wish I could go back to not
selling books is it bad to cater to
taste people want to love you Monk you
should let them love all of you there's
already so much Buzz because of the
movie deal Michael beat Jordan in
circling we want to put him on the cover
in one of those um scarves I guess you
would call them tied around his head a
doag doag that's it dag in a tank top
with the muscle showing something called
the fire
[Music]
department we're thinking we can get it
out in
H
Professor leis yes Anna ah nice to meet
you and you good
luck Dr FR sit please not there that's
the transformation couch you'd be
careful why would you come here to see
me if you disagree so passionately with
My Views you've insisted all your lives
that the very concept of God is
ludicrous yes cash between God and Satan
ah but I did not say whose side I was on
I consider what people tell me far less
interesting than what they choose not to
tell me have you frightened off your
professor yet not yet soon
perhaps you challenge my disbelief is
that great I do well done go too late to
stand back
now it seems to me Professor you never
matured enough to face the terror of
being alone in the
dark what is it you think can't Soo yeah
we're all
terrified do you bury your doubts you
bury your members of the war but at the
core of your
being we're all cowards before
death
looks
[Music]
hello hell hey so you're looking at me
from the
[Music]
street I'm assuming you're not with
anyone never see you with
anyone the moment
Dad yeah they died just before I was
12 I'm trying to write about them at the
moment how's it going
strangely
hi
hi is this
real does it feel
real oh boys back home our son look at
you you were just a boy now you're
not it was a long time ago yeah I don't
think that
matters maybe I treat
[Music]
you I I've always felt like a stranger
in my own family
maybe always scared of
something always running away do you
remember sorry I never came in your room
when you were
crying it's funny doesn't take
much to make you feel L way felt back
there again
[Music]
you think he'd like to be love with
him I'd always felt
love this is a new
feeling you and
me
[Music]
together into the
world
how come you don't laugh n ain't you got
something to make you just
[Music]
smile my sister and I ain't seen her in
years
you know if you ain't going to laugh you
need to sell your funny
bone I was married to a man I didn't
love whatever I say
[Music]
go and he took my sister away from me
even if we have to part you and me have
one
heart how come you so nice don't know
maybe you too nice
you seem like trouble I come here out of
respect but if there ain't nothing to
get that sure ain't n to
[Music]
give now I got your
attention here's what you need through
here drink
some push the button that going be some
changes made
me you got to stand
up I know my sister somewhere in the
world someday we going to meet
again keep your head held high just like
mom taught us it's time I be free from
you and enter into creation I died
before I let that happen good that's
just a going away present I've been
needing
baby baby
[Music]
baby what you got to do time for you to
see the world P the
button oh sweet and loving
God a
coming mama where baby they're monsters
it's okay
baby are you doing okay no I'm just
trying to take care of my
girl drop the bag on your knees right
now we got you on inent to distribute do
you want to keep your daughter get us to
silus I don't know him you better figure
it out 10 G's so when you get him you're
done heck got to go to work Bo
I'm stay dangerous
[Applause]
mama get in did she just get in the
[Music]
car call this in
now I haven't seen you in years give me
that money from that point forward you
and I are bonded how is she by the way
our
daughter she's got to be what like three
by now she's
five hey son it's a wire in his bed get
her
Jade put River on the phone where's my
daughter hi there we we can make this
right you want to see her again you
going to do exactly what I
[Music]
say it's time we call this in you want
to tell our boss we lost the CI we're
this close to nailing silus Butler H we
where is
he they target didn't me I didn't have a
choice I need some help I need a peace
whatever you're facing she'll protect
you from
it you can't go back there alone you
can't I have to now I'm just trying to
keep my head down take care of my
girl you wore a wire into my
home sit down this is detective carilla
requesting backup I can't let a snitch
go it's bad for
buiness I'm dumping your pond let him
[Music]
go